at its heart it's a simple story of a
powerful man paying hush money to cover
up an alleged sexual liaison
Donald Trump was a tycoon reality TV
star when he first met the porn actress
Stormy Daniels in 2006.
after playing in a celebrity golf
tournament here in Lake Tahoe he invited
her to his hotel room where she claims
they had sex
Ten Years Later during the 2016 election
campaign Trail and Miss Daniels was
trying to sell her story she since
published a memoir but at the time not
much was known about the affair
the Trump team was worried as this
damaging video had just emerged of him
talking lewdly and negatively about
women
hey when you're a star they let you do
it you can do anything whatever you want
grab them
could do anything
fast forward to the presents and the
exact charges of the indictment are
unknown but it is expected to focus on
allegations this man Michael Cohen
Trump's lawyer and fixer paid out a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars on
his boss's orders to buy the porn
actress's silence
something the former president has
always denied
[Music]
the coed was jailed after pleading
guilty to a number of charges including
Financial crimes
in his case Federal prosecutors ruled
the hush money was an improper donation
to the presidential campaign
his testimony will form a key part of
the evidence against Mr Trump there's
more than enough evidence to convict
because his documents emails other
Witnesses corroborating and the federal
prosecutors Gathering the evidence and
finding as a matter of fact
fact that Donald Trump instructed
Michael Cohn
the details of this case are undoubtedly
salacious but America is now entering
dangerous uncharted waters this will be
a big test for U.S democracy but it does
also send out a clear message that no
one including former presidents is above
the law
Alex Rossi Sky News